well simplifying our minimum wage it's
the goal of question two on your ballot
in the midterm election our minimum wage
is already going up a bit every year but
as John lingler explains supporters of
the measure want it to go up for the
same amount for everyone
back in 2019 Nevada lawmakers agreed the
state's minimum wage should go up
assembly Bill 456 created a 75 cent
increase every year until 2024. in July
it went up to 10.50 an hour or 9.50 an
hour that discrepancy is based on
whether an employer offers health
insurance and supporters of question 2
want it gone they should have been
paying their employees the right way all
along and offering health insurance
Annette Magnus is with battleborn
progress she says question 2 makes
minimum wage fair if approved instead of
two different increases everything stays
the same that's just what employers are
going to have to do they're going to
have to pay a living wage to contr to
continue to attract good employees Magna
says many employers are simply offering
bad health insurance that way they can
pay workers a dollar an hour less she
believes with the Affordable Care Act
companies can take advantage anymore
there is no reason that a business in
2022 should not not be able to pay the
minimum wage the current format We
Believe works for now employers and
employees Paul Murad Khan is with the
Vegas chamber this is redundant and not
necessary to amend the State
Constitution and while we're already
seeing that's the current state law he
points out Nevada's average hourly wage
is already 28 dollars an hour instead he
believes money should go towards job
training programs market demand will
drive the salaries especially for
qualified workers and I think that the
bigger issue for the chamber in this
conversation is that we're focusing on
the wrong solution for the problem this
measure already passed in the state
legislature twice putting it on the
ballot this year if approved it would
create one 12 an hour minimum wage by
2024. John langler 8 News Now